so i don't know if you're uh familiar
with this show or my stand-up from but
uh from time to time i like to refer to
myself as uh val kilmer specifically
lesbian vel kilmer
oh
that's fun and a little bit hurtful oh i
don't like how well it's doing just
watching
that's right
so we thought here at the pete home show
that we would take advantage of this
fact that i kind of look a little bit
like mr kilmer and do a segment oh god
you're still laughing
and do a segment that we call copying
val kilmer's twitter pics
copy his pics
all right so uh here's the first one
this is from his twitter that's just a
yeah
he loves he loves snapping selfies and
uh here's my best attempt at matching
yeah something about that
just feels right
uh here's another one of val he loves
the selfie that's awesome
uh so you think he's naked actually he's
wearing a very tasteful tube top in that
photo
at least i did for mine when i did it
like this
so yeah the ball's in your court now val
go to my twitter page check out my picks
and i really want to see if you can make
yourself look like me to give you an
example here's a here's something from
my instagram
yeah it's not so hard to make an
afternoon of it val kilmerize it there
you go
i want to see that happen i'll be your
wingman anytime